with this rubber band i'm going to show
you why it's so difficult to leave your
comfort zone especially what your
friends and family
do to hold you back not knowingly but
they do it to you so here we go
this hand represents you this hand
represents your friends and family
this is you saying i want to go do
something big with my life you go you go
you go but your friend's like wait a
minute come back down here what are you
doing you come back down
you go say ah i want a dream i want to
do something big your wife says babe
what are you talking about no no you're
working too hard
okay baby you're right no mom dad i i'm
so sick and tired of being broke son
come back down here we're not special
we're just regular
you think you're going to be a
millionaire one day and you keep going
eventually when you try to go and go the
tension gets harder
when you get to this point it's so
difficult to break away
because if you do it's going to snap
when it snaps a couple things happen
this illustration i showed it to group
last week on a zoom
look what happened to me it's not a big
cut but it's a cut when it hit back my
fingers started bleeding i wasn't even
looking at next you know i'm writing
there's blood all over my hands
like that's the pain we're afraid of
watch what happens so let me just show
it to you
so this is you and i we want to go
distance ourselves from our friends and
family because we have dreams you go you
go you go boom
that hurt right now but watch many of
you
you have not only one you have not only
two
so one represents your mom one
represents your wife or ex or
friend or peer or cousin another one and
another one
and another one and another one these
are all people that are holding you back
now watch watch how hard this is i want
to go
you can't right they're powerful okay
it's a very strong
power that they have on you when they
hold you back but if one by one by one
you show that you want to go out there
and win big eventually they're going to
realize how serious you are
by the way you know what the biggest
fear is look what happens to this when
i'm going to show it to you just watch
closely
when the disconnect when when this thing
this
when it cuts look how quickly this goes
meaning when you eventually get to a
point that they no longer have power
over your dreams they don't control you
anymore
your old habits your friends your family
you love these guys
but they're afraid of you separating
yourself from them it's an emotional
scenario that you're going to experience
but once you overcome that look how
quickly you explode watch
i'm going i'm going to go slow boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
your hand just goes up it explodes
and the separation goes by the way my
finger right now got cut as well the
separation's instant
pain pain pain pain i don't know if i
can do this
ah bam you're gone that's how life works
i'm a regular guy making 375 an hour
dude pat stop dreaming we're not meant
to do something big i don't want to live
a small life
pain pain pain boom then you make six
figures
and your peers are making six figures i
don't want to just make six figures
dude we're making more money than ever i
don't want to do something big boom
boom god boom you're going next i don't
want to just be an average guy but we
got a great life
at every single level new
people with these rubber bands shows up
it's not just your friends and family
at every level say you're an athlete
high school i want to go to college but
no
let's just high school ball no i want to
be disciplined
i don't want to smoke the weed and go
party like everybody else i want to play
in the nba
boom separation friend look at this girl
he cares about it himself
now you're playing college but i don't
want to just play in college i want to
go into me and be a boom
separation look at this guy he thinks
he's a guy that can go into the nba
he goes into i don't want to just be a
guy on the nba team i want to
this whole thing is so flippant scary
but it's so real
so the next time you're sitting there
and you're worried about the pain my
finger right now has pain
you're worried about that pain once you
make that distance and you go this way
let me put it to you this way i'm
experiencing certain things in my life
right now that makes no sense
certain things in my life right now that
makes no sense recently i just
got a property i didn't want to make it
public but all of a sudden everybody's
texting because when you buy a house
this size
everybody wants to write about it
because it's a record-breaking sale that
i had
do you know what it was like for me
living in an apartment complex in
glendale on 1323 broadway one bedroom my
sister and my mom when we were
broke now no money my mom ran out of
money going back to iran
i joined the army because i had nothing
to my name nothing
get out of the army i live with my
sister when i'm living with my sister
and i get out yummy i'm living with my
dad
trying to figure out life but i have
dreams
i want to do something big everybody's
holding me back
and then today you know what the next
level is
there's still people like that do you
know how much harder it is
for people to convince you to stay small
you know how much harder it is
you know what muscles you've developed
at this level
however you know how many of you are
actually going to go by the way right
later on today you know what's going to
happen to you and i talk to your friend
your wife your mom your dad
someone's going to say something you're
going to say you know what mom i want
you to watch a video you remind me of a
rubber band
what just watch this video mom don't be
a rubber band babe
baby i don't know what the hell you're
talking just watch this video you're
being a rubber man you don't even know
you're doing it
your wife will do it to you show them
this video your husband will do it to
you show them this video
your boyfriend will do it to you show
them this video your cousin will do to
you show them this video just say text
them
don't be my rubber band holding me back
let them think and after they watch this
video if somebody share this video with
you
let that person go after their dreams
stop
holding them back and hopefully maybe
you are also joined them on the journey
of wanting to do something big with
their lives if this
made any sense to you to look at rubber
bands in a whole different way i got
another video i want you to watch it's a
video i did
a couple years ago i gave a message at
this one event in long beach
uh and it was called think like a grand
master entrepreneur if you type an
entrepreneur on your phone it's one of
the first videos that comes up but if it
doesn't
click over here go watch that video i
talk to you about step-by-step mindset
mindset on how
i went from just being a regular guy to
thinking about my next 5
10 15 steps if you've never seen that
video click over here and if you've not
subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye